[Music]
well good evening and welcome to Tucker
Carlson tonight we're nearing the end of
our second full week of total saturation
Ukraine coverage that means every
channel every hour of the day so at this
point you'd think it would be obvious
what exactly the fuss is about after
this much talking you would assume every
person in America would understand what
crimes Donald Trump is being accused of
committing but no even now the story
still feels obscure and strangely light
there's nothing mysterious or waiting
about it we already know all of the
facts there's a transcript and yet they
still don't seem very shocking and so
maybe for that reason our news anchors
have been doing their very best to keep
the blood pressure high the game is
boring so the cheerleaders have to work
overtime twice as hard for example here
was MSNBC's best attempt to get you to
care I don't say this lightly but let's
be frank a national nightmare is upon us
the basic rules of our democracy are
under attack from the president we begin
tonight with a series of admissions by
the president that all but assures his
impeachment in the House of
Representatives this moment should
arguably be a national emergency the
founding fathers would have considered
it a national emergency if the president
publicly lobbied multiple foreign
governments to interfere in the next
election it's tough to say lightly but
this is the moment that we're asked what
they get cliche bombed this one off try
to ignore how hackneyed and badly
written that speech was the state of
education in this country clearly is in
rapid decline nobody can run a decent
paragraph anymore some day we're gonna
do a special on that but for now
consider the substance of what you just
heard to dissent there wasn't he the
basic rules of our democracy are under
attack that's what they're telling you
so what exactly are the basic rules of
our democracy well the most basic rule
of all is that the people rule in a
democracy
the big decisions are made by voters in
elections they are not made by left-wing
talk-show hosts or by The Washington
Post or even by high-level CIA employees
acting anonymously as whistle
no in a democracy the main decisions are
made by citizens casting ballots that
for example is how you remove a
president by beating him in an election
that's always the way we did it here in
America
not anymore so yes our democracy is
under attack they're right about that
and yet for all his faults Donald Trump
is not the attacker but wait a second
they're telling you we understand how
grave a decision impeachment is in fact
we're praying over it people of faith
that we are but in this case impeachment
is unavoidable soliciting information
from foreign countries is corrupt and
evil that's what they're telling you
okay fine but let's at least acknowledge
that this standard is a brand new
standard I mean brand-new standard like
20 minutes ago because it wasn't that
long ago less than a year you'll
remember this that all of American
politics revolved around information
solicited from foreign countries it was
called the steel dossier and back then
the press corps strongly approved of it
the allegations in this Christopher
steel dossier and you went through the
timeline very well a few moments ago are
stunning they're actually substantial
portions of what was in the steel
dossier which was a raw intelligence
document that have indeed checked out
based on our own reporting and word from
numerous official sources the dossier in
fact is far from bogus I think we're
gonna actually have to stop calling it
the infamous dossier increasingly it's
the accurate dossier increasingly it's
the damning dossier increasingly it's
the dossier that is going to hang around
the neck of the Trump administration and
drag them down oh the dossier was
totally fine in case you've forgotten
and you may have forgotten because why
would you remember but Christopher
Steele who wrote the dossier was a
foreign intelligence operative he
gathered his material abroad in foreign
countries some of it clearly from
foreign government officials at the time
that was absolutely fine with Democrats
they weren't embarrassed to say so
Clinton campaign staffer Brian Fallon
tweeted this we could give you a million
samples here's one here's his tweet I
regret I didn't know about Christopher
Steele's hiring pre-election if I
had I would have volunteered to go to
Europe and try to help him oh okay and
by the way if foreign interference is
such a concern and by the way it should
be a concern then why are we more
worried about foreign companies sending
de facto bribes to the family members of
connected politicians there are a lot of
those we're picking on Joe Biden's son
because it's in the news but it could be
a lot of people's sons
trust me but in the case of Biden's son
nobody thinks he's an expert on
Ukrainian energy policy he got the gig
because of his dad it was
influence-peddling
obviously in this case that's okay
though for some reason so let's just be
totally honest let's stop lying if we
can just for a second I know it's hard
in modern America where everyone's
required to lie all the time but let's
just be honest for this one moment in
Washington right now there are no actual
rules partisan simply invent standards
for the purpose of destroying their
political enemies just today Hillary
Clinton tweeted this from a late
democratic member of Congress this quote
if the impeachment provision the
Constitution of the United States will
not reach the offenses charged here then
perhaps that 18th century Constitution
should be abandoned to a 20th century
paper shredder Barbara Jordan by the way
in other words if the process doesn't
reach the outcome that Hillary Clinton
wants it to reach she thinks we ought to
scrap the Constitution oh probably not a
question that that concept appeals to
Michigan congresswoman were suited to
lead this week to lead told her
constituents that the Democratic Party
is now considering ways to arrest
members of trumps cabinet jailing them
in Detroit would be a good option she
explained watch this so they're trying
to figure out
so I just want you to know I will relay
your messenger I will tell them they can
hold those people ready to take care of
them just fit on rest him that's not
third world or anything arrest the
cabinet you got to give sleeve credit
for honesty anyway she's not pretending
to be prayerful like Nancy Pelosi she's
just saying what she really thinks and
she speaks for unfortunately quite a few
people on her party what we're watching
here what she just watched in that clip
is politics itself breaking down that's
not politics of course that's not the
effort to persuade people bring them
over to your side through a reason no
that's something different
modern partisans on the Left don't want
to just win the next election electoral
power is too transient voters might
change their mind in the election after
that it happens by the way in 2016
Democrats don't want to take that risk
again so they've moved on from the goal
of winning votes to utterly destroying
their opponents their enemies they want
them imprisoned as you just heard
they're with their families intimidated
then with the supporters humiliated and
demoralized they want to vanquish rather
than win over that's not a good way to
run a country but it's an awfully
effective way to maximize political
power